اضطر الناتو إلى التدافع على الطائرات المقاتلة هذا
الأسبوع ، ما الذي يمكن أن تخبرنا به أكثر من
ذلك ، لقد تلقينا جميعًا في السلك الصحفي
منذ وقت قصير
بيانًا من القيادة الجوية لحلف الناتو
كان مفاجئًا بعض الشيء أنهم قالوا إنه
منذ يوم الثلاثاء  اضطررت إلى التدافع على
الطائرات المقاتلة عدة مرات فوق
منطقة البلطيق والبحر الأسود
بسبب اقتراب طائرات مجهولة الهوية
الآن من هذه
الطائرات المجهولة التي يقولون إنها
روسية ، والملف الشخصي النموذجي للطائرة الروسية هو
عدم الإعلان عن عدم إرسال
إشارات مع أي أجهزة إرسال فقط للطيران
معها.  لا توجد خطة طيران وما يقوله الناتو
وأريد أن أفهمه تمامًا
للجميع أنه منذ يوم الثلاثاء قاموا
بتدافع طائرات مقاتلة من بولندا
والدنمارك وفرنسا وإسبانيا ورومانيا والمملكة المتحدة
فوق بحر البلطيق والبحر الأسود
عندما اقتربت هذه الطائرات الروسية من
هناك  لا يوجد مؤشر في هذه
المرحلة على أي طائرة أمريكية تدافعت ولا يوجد
مؤشر على دخول الروس إلى
المجال الجوي لحلف شمال الأطلسي أو الحلفاء
ولكنه  تجدر الإشارة إلى أننا لم
نر هذه الأنواع من
مسارات الطيران منذ عدة أسابيع ، لقد سألنا
الناتو عنها كثيرًا ، ويقولون
إنهم لم يروا الروس
يطيرون حقًا بهذه الطريقة ، والآن يبدو أنهم
قد فعلوا
ذلك ، فهذا شيء كبير.  صفقة لأن
المسؤولين الروس بمن فيهم
الرئيس وصفوا
هذا بأنه صراع مع الناتو ، لذا لرؤية
اختبار الطائرات الروسية ساري المفعول
، أوقات استجابة الناتو وما إلى ذلك في
المجال الجوي ،
استمع إلى أنها تمثل مخاطر أيضًا
للتصعيد المحتمل.